we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p here's a caller
who is understandably confused about the
great replacement theory stuff espoused
by the buffalo shooter take a listen to
this
hey david that shooter in buffalo cited
great replacement theory
that makes no sense to me because it's
not like
black people in this country for the
most part are immigrants i know some are
but they their their ancestors were
forcefully
immigrated immigrated over here you
could say but i just don't see the logic
how he would use that as an excuse to
kill that particular demographic i don't
either um
do they actually believe that
black people are being
sent in here by democrats or something
so here's what you have to understand
it's a great point which is great
replacement theory
is focused on forcing demographic
changes upon the united states through
immigration but for the most part the
people that are coming to the united
states legally and illegally are not
black people as traditionally defined so
why would you go and shoot black people
if you're angry about great replacement
theory
all you have to understand is this
for a lot of these folks there's white
people
and then there's everybody else
so it doesn't matter that great
replacement is more about the
immigration of what you know we might
call brown latino hispanic people and
the shooter went and targeted black
people it's just it's all non-white
people now there's sometimes an
exception there's something called the
ideal immigrant story about asian folks
so sometimes these same people who are
angry about
black brown people coming to the united
states
in order to try to justify themselves
not actually being racist xenophobes
they'll go
we're fine with people coming from and
they'll usually list asian countries
they'll say like south korea and stuff
like that
this is this is called the model
minority or the ideal minority uh it's
it's another trope that's often part of
this so but generally speaking there
it's if it's not white people
that's their concern and so
that's the connection between great
replacement and black folks even though
it doesn't actually make much sense
since most black folks are indeed
born here in the united states i i'm
trying to explain something that doesn't
make sense
so i hope i've at least explained what
they believe accurately we have a great
bonus show for you today we are going to
talk about a dutch doctor that will keep
sending abortion pills to american women
we will explain how north korea went
from zero covid to 1.2 million cases in
just 72 hours and we will talk about a
supreme court decision that will make
ted cruz a half a million dollars richer
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com if
you're waiting for our big memorial day
membership discount you can get on our
newsletter at davidpakman.com and on
monday memorial day you'll get an email
telling you how to sign up at a massive
discount